guys i'm coming on the road i would love
to see you we've been having a blast
just go to
salvolcanocomedy.com for all tickets uh
i'm at the ryman in march 11th i uh the
next day i am at the tivoli theater in
chattanooga then we got all sorts of fun
stuff we got louisville we got
evansville we got tulsa and okc oklahoma
you've been asking me to come there i am
on the way get those right away um the
beacon theater my hometown i've been
banging that drum a lot but this will be
my first headline ever that's may 14th
and then of course i have san diego and
la may 21st and 22nd love to see you
guys please come on out folks march 10th
through the 12th i will be in
philadelphia pa
at the punchline comedy club i think
it's three shows maybe four maybe five
i think it's five i think it's five
shows you gotta come out to one of them
then on april 14th i'm going to be in
irvine california at the irvine improv
one show only 8 pm that night then i'm
heading right
down to san diego from there to do a
bunch of shows i'm going to be in austin
texas
may 20th and 21st to win four shows at
the creek and cave
come out to see all these things and
also if you're in new york city
come to joey rose's if you're interested
in stand up and comedy shows go to joe
derosa info.com for tickets and
information if you're interested in
coming to the bar and sandwich shop i've
opened go to joeyrosesnyc.com
for info and hours and everything else
and there's a new secret sandwich called
the disgusting pig
swish
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds hey taste buddies welcome to
the taste buds podcast
slash youtube
show because it is never called that
before but also you said it
half-heartedly and at the end of you
saying it i was like i didn't know if
you believed it or not or you were just
like i don't know if it is i always feel
weird when i go and i say to somebody we
have a podcast that's on youtube i'm
like i should say it's a youtube show a
youtube show right that's a thing right
we have a youtube show
technically we have our own tv i just
noticed your shirt yeah oh my god that's
supporting yeah i'm supporting that's my
new merch yeah i love it dude this shirt
by the way nice soft worn
like an old band tee right yeah yeah
large yeah
the fit you're cooking with both the
large and the other design remember it
was like a goddamn corset on me are you
talking about the uh are you talking
about the the the step cracking yeah you
gotta go maybe go up a size there that's
a little note for all of you ordering
the uh merch go up besides this is also
the god bless hoodie these will all be
on for they're not already because this
comes down a couple weeks this is
probably up online already yeah if it's
not
i don't know what to tell you but it'll
be up soon that's exciting yeah that's
exciting we were working on joey rose's
merch last night oh sweet [ __ ] yeah oh
i would love some well the one i'm
excited about is
we're gonna have a shirt that says
it's just going to say our spokesperson
isn't in prison joey rosie
because of the implication that it
sounds like a mafioso type place no
cause jared from subway is in
prison oh i don't know if i make that
connection
you're i mean you're a social club and
stand-alone new york city custom
sandwich shop i don't put you against
subway it's about it's about the
sandwiches i wanted
i wanted to say this is what i wanted it
to say i wanted to spokesperson you
maybe you say a spokesperson is not
imprisoned for child pornography
that's about a t-shirt the guy the guy
decided our merch kept saying that he
kept going no it's got to be our
spokesperson who's in a pedophile and
me and paul are going we can't have that
on a t-shirt that's insane but uh but
our spokesperson isn't in prison our
spokesperson is not imprisoned for
questionable choices
you put this down here it looks like uh
we decided shout outs yeah hello shout
out to wyoming whiskey great people over
there
a lot of involvement with the bar here
we're at joey rose's by the way cheers
it's a strong bourbon but it's good it's
so good it's delicious i just normally
don't drink perfect straight wow yeah i
got you per se and not uh
not you know that was a big shot you
just did too so i thought you poured it
for me to consume it as a one to one i
didn't i didn't know if i judged maybe
that's right no this is our first time
back since your opening day last time
yes yes we've now been open for a few
months and we're back to talking about
pedophilia
for this sure
yeah there was a lot
for the fans there's a lot there's a lot
of bonus features cut out of that
podcast that you did not see because i
was stressed it might be coming up in
the no press doc we don't know i was
stressing that day dude we were
we were recording up until the second we
opened that night yeah you you seem now
like a world away like you're you're a
seasoned vet now it's it's it's a lot
goes by in a few months yeah shout out
to the gentleman who sent us this along
with all the other artwork he sent this
is one of my favorite things of all time
as far as taste buds going as far as
taste buds artwork go and i've had a
huge response from this of for friends
and family he asked if we would wear
this thanks for getting that done v he
asked if we would thank you v
he asked you if he asked me if we would
wear this on a t-shirt i said yes i
would i just didn't want him to have to
make merch because we're getting merch
i would love to make that a t-shirt and
even give him something for doing it for
us but i'm not sure if we could sell
we could sell that i don't think we're
allowed without getting without getting
in trouble i mean we're going to be off
the snapple labels just to drink them
yeah yeah but uh
but i would love to have it oh by the
way we've we forgot to do the opening
chat
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds
um
yeah we're back in the rose room at
joey rose's 174 rivington street come
visit us uh where it's monday so we're
not open on monday so we're back here
recording all day we're in the rose room
we're doing a bunch of episodes today
right we're coming to you live from the
rose room yeah joey rose yeah
uh 174.0 on your fm die
you're tuned to the smooth sounds of
joey rose is that rivington you should
did you ever do that for a living what
did you ever do any djing
no for a living not for i mean like some
a lot of guys like radio stuff you guys
moonlighted on radio like like a lot of
guys here and there picked up stuff you
can name 20 people 20 friends 20 people
i will come dead last in the category of
ranking diction
really yeah i don't think and even for
voiceovers and stuff i've all you got
like jay and and soda
they have such good radio voices and you
do too you really do i'm a sloppy i i
sound like i have marbles in my mouth
sometimes my accent's heavy sometimes
it's not i i i is born for it
he's born for it yeah
his regular voice maybe he's maybe he's
born for it maybe it's maybelline
is that maybelline
i did a joke for a little while where
it's like maybe
what was that it was like eyelash and
makeup no no no no no not what was
maybelline
what was that slogan you just did why
don't you be true why what is i don't
remember that slogan that you just sang
it's maybelline's only slogan no the
first line though maybe she's born with
it maybe it's maybelline really that's
it i used to do a joke like maybe she's
born with it maybe it's maybelline hey
maybelline maybe she's just [ __ ] born
with it yeah like enough like it's not
like don't take credit like you're not
[ __ ] like let the girl be a natural
beauty yeah she's like maybe i'm born
beautiful and they're like well maybe
it's us yeah
it is a shitty thing to say
like you look gorgeous is that you no
it's the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah they can't be
you that's the makeup right right
yeah yeah that's a shitty thing maybe
i'll start that up again yeah
maybe i'll start that up again
it's definitely works now in this very
you know we're all progressively moving
toward the same things
yes i agree true true yeah yeah it is
true it is true today's battle by the
way i don't think that they can get away
with that right now if that's that's
that right now i think nobody could arms
you couldn't
you couldn't do they had to be they'd
have to make a slogan slogan maybe she's
born with it ads are nuts
like if you go look at past ads i do it
all the time yeah you go on youtube and
put in like 1980s or 1990s commercials
and i'll watch like a four hour super
cut yeah i spend my time wisely i had a
i had a joke
i had a joke about
if you looked up old whiskey whiskey and
bourbon ads and stuff from the 50s
because they were literally like it
literally be like a wife and it'd be
like hey fellas you ever get tired of
her running her mouth
why don't you drink some of this
it'll tune around for a few hours like
the ads literally were like when your
wife is getting on your nerves
drink some johnny walker
it's funny because like for many people
that still is exactly what it's for but
you can't say that no you can't market
it to those people but that's why they
drink it yeah no it's what it's wild
but to escape problems that was a big
that was another big thing like that
would like marketing in the 50s and 60s
it was more of the 50s but it was geared
towards the wives for like
you know if you want your husband to be
happy oh he comes home and you greet him
you should be wearing this yeah yeah you
remember those crazy yeah yeah it's wild
yeah it's crazy it's like so just like
you know like but talk about times
changing ten years later they people
were like no way
right
like 10 you know you look at 55 to 65.
yeah and those companies according to
this timeline those companies should be
cancelled for doing that
there's not there's no there's no
evolution allowed there's no gross
allowed no yeah i'm a believer in
evolution yeah
me too i'm a huge believer in evolution
it's evolution baby yeah that's my
favorite project yeah you gotta let
people grow i mean that's what we are
yeah
we've evolved i mean we're not we almost
coming from that we're not tadpoles
anymore if you said who we are that
would have been another pearl jam title
yes no who you
who you are right who are we who are we
who we are you talk about yield no no
code it's on no code when they went a
little goofy no code then yields right
yeah i yield i stopped and let me tell
you something this is nothing against
pearl jam because man oh man for like
from from from uh
10. through yield i i mean i i would
listen to that on repeat all day long
everything was my college years it was
like and then i don't know what it was i
think but i think i just got
it was just too much of it that's an
extraordinary album
i think you did versus your their peak
in on versus into into vitology yeah
yeah no code was a slight drop and then
yield was a slight drop i felt no code
was interesting yield is not a good
album but contains two of the greatest
program songs ever do the evolution and
brain of jay the first song on that
record is it's insane no code was a
really cool if you remember the album
put together really cool it was like all
those pictures and had those inserts
that you'd pull out that looked like i
think they looked like postcards oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah no i thought that
was that's got some good stuff that's
got hale hale on it yeah and that's got
um red mosquito and that's got yeah
there's some good songs on that album
yeah but um but yeah it's a departure
that's exactly yeah you're talking about
ten verses and even bytology but most
likely front to back is like are you
kidding me
some of the best rock songs it's funny
10 i recognize as a great record i can
never listen to it anymore because it's
it's be it became like that first rage
against the machine record where it's
i've heard it so many times and then
also too it's so polished compared to
the following two i like when rage got a
little like dirty with the sound yeah
then you go back to that first one and
it's so [ __ ] polished and that's the
same thing
that rage was at the los angeles one
battle of los angeles that album is
awesome after that one
renegade's a funk yeah yeah that's all
the covers renegades are funk is okay
um you know what let me blow your balls
off okay
um
when we were born like what we consider
right now classic rock
has been considered classic rock
since maybe the 90s or even the 80s like
it was classic rock nearly immediately
right like 70s rock it's like yeah it
was already called classic right now we
transitioned to like glam rock yeah and
metal and things like that
when we were born i was born in the mid
70s and even go to the 90s you're
referencing classic rock which is 20
years old pearl jam that album right now
is over 30 years old it's 30 years old
about
so in in in that definition of classic
rock this is beyond even
it's a decade beyond what we were
calling classic rock when we were that
far removed from the actual cell well if
you turn on a classic rock station now
you'll hear stuff from the 90s on it
like it's been absorbed in oh they've
changed what it means
it just so it's just
rock of a certain age that's all classic
rock beans yeah but then what are they
then how do you define what classic
rocky used to mean
i i mean i think they just i mean i'm
going to think i'm going to throw on a
classic rock station here like a three
doors down
well i think you
i might be talking out of my ass but i
don't think i am i think like you would
hear
some early not see it's tough with some
of the stuff because grunge is such a
specific genre there's usually a station
just for grunge but then there's other
stuff from that era that i think you
would hear yeah like there's pearl jam
stuff that they would throw in on like
the unlike the dylan station
you know what i mean or whatever because
it's it harkens or where neil young
style station because it's it's there's
a connective tissue there you know and
then there's nothing connected to now
what is rock now for real i couldn't
tell you i couldn't tell you either
spoon's the only rock stations spoon is
the only one you get a spoon on like an
alternative rock band i did too they're
like kind of they're pretty amazing
i guess foo fighters which are great
rock band but they're like one of a kind
you want to hear something crazy this
this [ __ ] me up when i sorry i keep
saying the f's but this this messed me
up when i thought of it
foo fighter's been around
three times as long as nirvana at this
point yeah it's crazy yeah like that's
more established for david roll then
they're still relevant did you see the
new movie no i mean i saw the trailer
but i haven't seen it oh so you know
what i'm talking about i probably see it
for my podcast you know what i'm talking
about yeah i was i saw that yeah that
unexpectedly there's a horror movie
starring the foo fighters coming out
which is so genius it's like the
throwback to all those old band movies
yeah yeah it's great
it looks funny yeah
jeff garland's in the trailer and it
cracks me up
because he's so jeff garland all the
time yeah and he can see it in the
trailer he goes he goes phone fighters
he yells it's so loud
it just makes me feel like but you want
to talk classic rock it's saying classic
rock is all the music made from the 60s
through the 90s see wow
but that's that's weird because then you
have some sections of that rock you know
well i think it was more like it was a
formatting thing that radio stations
yeah
but do you want to hear
the 80s
can i tell you the song i keep listening
to the last three days please because
the album that defined my generation
the reset album i i got to experience
two of them so did you in rock music
appetite for destruction
and never mind those were the two reset
albums that we got to where that where
everybody was like this just changed
everything changed the game yeah so
appetite to me is like you think
appetite i would say you're probably i
mean people we were absolutely
roses was the biggest of those bands and
that was the biggest up there and they
also did it better than anybody they
didn't there was no glamminess to it
like it was they were awesome no they
had some glam well later but appetite
was like as ac dc as any of those bands
ever got you know what i mean okay
i think axel was in leather black
leather pants but he didn't have the
like on the jungle video he does but
they didn't have makeup on and all you
know what i mean they look yeah they
look like dirty dudes yeah yeah poison
was like it was the same it was like a
little yeah they were still considered
the same but yeah it was there was a
division there but i didn't know this
until two days ago
guns and roses has a new song out
this thing flew so under the radio radar
it's called hard school
it's it's a jam dude it's axel slash pop
as the kid said yeah it's actual slash
and duff dude it's the heart it's the
original trio no and dude it is
awesome
really and it sounds like guns and roses
it sounds like this would have came out
right after appetite for destruction
it's like an anthemic it's hot it's
awesome i can't stop this is a single
it's just a single
wow and is it getting radio play you
know i don't listen to the choices
i didn't even know it existed two days
ago it came out in september how did we
not hear about the new guns and roses
with most of the original lineup song
coming out yeah that's crazy i think
this is how we feel
but it's just because like
the i mean that people don't know we
know guns you guys like guns and roses
do you know them yeah you know
i don't know them by name you know
welcome to the jungle yes paradise city
sweet child of mine obviously
so you know those okay that's cool yeah
i have an original pressing of appetite
for destruction on vinyl and it's like
i'm gonna spin that when i get home
tonight that record is like there's not
a bad song on it yeah it is a classic
you go through i know that's like a
thriller to me where it's like front to
back
you can't mess with it mr brownstone's
on that my michelle it's so easy it's so
easy night train i train oh my god um my
uh you said my michelle uh crate you're
crazy
rocket queen
rocky queen i think is
how does that one go
what's the course here i am your rocket
queen yeah for me that was the weakest
song on the album i love that song
think about you
there's another one i think about you
yeah
[Music]
you sound a little like uh ac dc there
he does yeah he sounds kind of like
brian jones so i saw them um in uh this
episode staples center i think yeah and
uh it was when they were doing the tour
a few years ago
and i was like you know like there was
some press where like you're like oh
axel's like huffing around the stage and
it's just not the same it's a little bit
weird that was not the case dude
i went he killed he did not stop moving
and i thought he was gonna like cheap
out on the notes and he hit every note
well that's what i'm dude in this new
song he's doing the like wow
like he's doing all that i'm like jesus
god dude it sounds it's it's an awesome
song i can't stop listening doesn't it
feel like so much more style and nuance
and like i don't know went into that
type of music it was such a thing like
no one's no one's screaming like that it
was epic yeah epic tunes yeah i don't
think rock is a thing nowadays i don't
think it's like a rock station um
well there's not really a lot of is
there even anybody just turned into pop
honestly yeah like pop is like an
amalgamation of everything i guess but i
feel like the last phase of like
new rock music and it wasn't great was
like that phase of like well no
it was the matchbox 20 phase yeah which
sucked that was like
but then after that there was the phase
where it was like kings of leon i
thought that matchbox 20 sucked but i
think matchbox 20 was more like top 40
and it wasn't like well i guess actually
great guns and roses was too i guess
yeah it's just shifting yeah but like
that that run of like kings of leon i
always call that like the festival rock
because like yeah they were the guys the
sons of
who were they mumford and sons like oh
that started doing like the like that
like indie rock indie rock focusing i'm
not a big mumford instructor
like in like the mid mid arts oh some of
it's great i'd love to know what what
you think of drake you ever sit down and
listen to drake
knock knock who's there hello hello
hello fresh well you got me
hello fresh is uh america's number one
meal kit if you listen to the taste buds
you know all about it and uh we'll tell
you again because we love it i i
actually cooked with hello fresh this
week i made i made bolognese pasta oh
yeah yeah there you go it was it was
good it was really good yeah it was easy
for two i cooked it for two okay this
one did both
[Laughter]
cook different two ate both
with hello fresh you're getting wrong
sal likes what salax is in his home in
his private time it's he'll cook a meal
for two and then uh he wears a an outfit
where it's a half of it's a tuxedo the
other a ball gown
and he'll
he'll turn back and forth as he eats
from both plates
that's so funny with that little fries
you get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep skip
trips to the grocery store and count our
hellofresh to make home cooking easy fun
and affordable it's why it's america's
number one meal kit uh we'll tell you a
little bit about it right wholesome
recipes for satisfying nutritious meals
right i love it six recipes per week to
choose from including low calorie and
carb conscious options i like when they
when you have the options to pick things
that go along with whatever diet it is
you're pursuing you can customize it
right hellofresh is also 72 cheaper than
a restaurant meal of the same quality
that's huge because often a lot of us go
i'm just gonna go to the restaurant
because i don't feel like dealing with
this right now or i don't have the time
i love that it's cheaper
than a restaurant and still restaurant
quality also you can save on average 65
or more per month i'll tell you to order
hellofresh instead of grocery store
shopping yes of course it's cheaper but
what i like too is you can tailor it so
you don't just have to choose from their
pre preset options if you want more of a
certain protein you can choose more of a
certain protein taylor right to you so
it really is like
there's no barrier to like oh i don't
like this i don't like that you make it
how you want it yeah um uh go to
hellofresh.com tastebuds16 and use the
code taste buds one six and you've heard
this before for up to 16
free meals and three free gifts okay
that's hellofresh.com
tastebuds16 and use the code tastebuds16
for up to 16 free meals and three free
gifts uh hello fresh america's number
one meal kit we started selling merch
and we need a way to sell it
and uh but i also opened a new business
joey rose's right now and you have a lot
of mail has to go back and forth are you
spending all your days running out and
going to the post office well we're
about to launch merch now for the bar
okay and one of the things that is
making it a less daunting uh concept and
something that i think is palatable and
do-it-all
ship station is already trusted by over
100 000 e-commerce
sellers shipstation will help you keep
track of orders from any sales channel
uh it's easily the way to find the best
shipping carrier with deeply discounted
rates and you can automate just about
any shipping task with just a few clicks
you don't worry about shipping again you
do it uh from where you are quickly
affordably and painlessly
um online shopping shopping isn't going
to slow down
that's it now we've we've kicked it into
overdrive so and i i gotta say my my
favorite and i've said it before
my favorite thing about shipstation is
the fact that
when you wanna a lot of times when you
start these sort of online independent
businesses
the hardest thing is the mail order
aspect of it
go there's nothing worse than going to
the post office much love to the post
office shouts out to the post office but
it's a pain
and it takes forever and it'll make you
not pursue a business everyone
understands this so shipstation is here
to let you do it easily you can put
affordably all your orders you can
funnel them into one interface so no
matter what you're selling so you manage
every order amazon ebay etsy all on your
own website you save money compared to
going to other carrier options also you
can do it from anywhere even on your
phone which is nice so save that sanity
and know that you're getting the best
rate ship more in less time with ship
station use our offer code taste buds to
get a a 60-day free trial 60 days that's
two months to you and me two months free
of a no hassle stress free uh shipping
alternative just go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type in taste
buds
ship station
make ship happen
i think drake is a great i know he's
your god i know he's everyone's gone
he's a great i think he's a very very
skilled rapper and i think he's very
good at what he does but it's his music
just isn't for me i don't like that
underwater where the beats all sound
like it's underwater
even though i appreciate the sort of
uniqueness of it i find it boring i just
i i just came from like
like when you like when you got a new
public enemy record i don't want to be
that guy now that's going to sound like
so old but but but before he does this
please before he does this please get
off our lawn yeah
but i mean when you got a new public
enemy record with like a new nwa record
or when the chronic came out but
definitely they've that's how that you
you put it on yay's the only one that's
kind of still doing that sort of album
but like
you put that by his new name yeah
his legal name yeah he changed it yeah
you but you dude when you i remember
when i got the chronic i got it for
christmas
and i remember putting that on at my
buddy's house at a party and we were
like
holy [ __ ] let's sit here and listen to
every song every lyric yeah yeah it was
so big like i remember when i got doggy
style it was like such a huge i remember
every dog
every song
every song connected it was like this
sound montage that just blasted at you
from front to back that's the and you
listen i feel like there's not a lot of
that anymore i just want a musical he
listens like all the new music weekly
right all of it yeah you consume it like
that which is that but i don't know it
was like now it's like you're just like
oh new music like on here but it used to
be like who got it and then like go and
like listen to it kind of almost
together dude you had to well kanye i
just bought one of his 200 music players
he just sold his album for 200 a copy
yeah yeah is that is that a thing is
that really happening yeah he's fighting
with apple they pulled their 200 million
deal with him oh is that what i saw both
headlines because he wanted to price
point 200 no because he's not publishing
to streaming services you have to buy it
like an nft from him
really i bought one well i mean it's
that's cool and all but i think woo did
that the best i mean it was one two
million dollar album
yeah
he already made two million
oh he made it already already
and
it was a 200 million dollar deal
that they pulled yanked from him for
disrespecting them
disrespecting that he's fighting apple
wow
the uh but that's just the thing pimp it
was like great okay
it is fun it is fun to watch
special effects
yeah i got to watch it despite the fact
that he's threatening friends of ours
on a daily basis
leave a buddy alone
but uh but no dude it's it's it's like
pimp this was like a thing where it was
like
you had to like
you when you went to get like a record
like the chronic that was anticipated
it would sell out
yeah and you would have to wait and then
the other thing was if you wanted
something that wasn't like main street
like i was such a hip-hop head right so
like you have to go to space when like i
want it like to get like the third dos
effects album after they weren't big in
the mainstream anymore i would have to
call record stores and be like did you
get the new dos fx in
and because you because some stores
wouldn't order it if they were like we
don't sell a lot of hip hop that you
they wouldn't have it it was like a
thing dude you had to really so when an
album sucked you were like mother
[ __ ] yeah because it cost you like you
spent 16 bucks in the 90s 16 bucks was a
lot more money yeah and when it sucked
you were just like
what i went through to get this thing i
know it's terrible it's also it's also
cool to work for it a little bit
i like that i really like that like
you're extending yourself you're
investing yourself you're making a call
you're taking a drive you know you're
like i don't know you might be sold out
you're like i don't know there's
something in that but my counter
argument to this is that nowadays people
live in the scene of their music through
all the videos on youtube and stuff
like these little kids live the scene
right they're obsessed with it all day
long i don't know if that makes it
yeah it's just different it was it was
it was kids live in the scene back then
it was just different you know what i
mean there's a different way to
appreciate it now that's all like i
think the love is still the love
it's just um
it's just you know you're always look
when you're when you're in your 40s
you're going to be like man i miss when
it was like i every friday i would get
my new thing on my apple whatever
whatever it is there'll be some new way
of doing it like remember little zan
i miss him
remember when little zane's album
dropped i will say this i will say this
download the one thing the one thing you
guys don't have
which is it's a shame
with rap music at least
when it in the 90s it was like
everybody had a different style and
every producer was so unique so because
you could sample still back then so
beats were like
the sky was the limit dude like
everybody's record sounded different
because everybody's producer sampled
this just sounds the same today so but
but but so it's the saw but then
everybody else had a different style so
like
in the 90s it was like what's this guy
gonna say like i remember when cyprus
hill came out and we were like who is
this guy that's rapping like a bird this
is crazy like that like yo
you don't hear that since i was on the
way home but you know what they didn't
you know what they didn't have yeah yeah
yeah you know what they didn't have back
then salsa windfall
new software for coming soon
coming soon i'm serious download it
immediate download it's coming soon
drake i uh greg has hit or missed me
drake's been around now for [ __ ]
about 20 years almost i mean like 15
years he's been number one for the whole
time he's i mean he's he's like one of
the last big you know like last well no
that's not true but like of my like you
know a little bit before but he
he has some
crazy like bangers for me and then
someone's like ah it's not for me like
when he gets to a little too and didn't
he help like pass the baton to like the
mumble
wasn't he like the beginning of like the
in your feelings kind of like he helped
it but there was no stopping it yeah
yeah i mean right now hip hop is like
it's almost like
emo punk
it's great yeah i love it yeah you know
what we should do but it's like most of
it outside of like a few outliers unless
i'm unless i'm completely just out of
touch but like i mean kendrick is still
like you know like this like i i like
that i like you know what i mean
something yeah kendrick
sorry
the production and there's this
influences of old music you know we need
to do you guys reacting to new music
videos oh that's dope i would do that
for sure do that
for sure i'll show you guys some weird
[ __ ] yeah
was like another one of the last like
really like like amazing lyricists like
right now i don't feel like it's about
lyrics right now i do like the kendrick
drake kendrick drake and kanye are three
of the guys that are massively popular
that also sound
you know them like when you hear them
yeah that's that's that guy
a lot of the other guys like it's like
it's fair but i'd agree it's very
emotional now when that all started the
vulnerability and rap started with
biggie tupac and eminem like that's when
it started nowhere biggie was the first
that's the other thing it's like when
biggie came out and he was like talking
about how he went to kill himself like
that was crazy yeah the ghetto boys were
the only guys that even graced that
touched on that scarface would talk
about depression houston but like yeah
but like that was crazy it was crazy
when eminem came out and started talking
about like how bad his life was it was
crazy when tupac was like like soulfully
like reflecting
like is eminem considered like to you
guys like older now or is he still so
relevant that because he's just like so
he's going to be a living legend to me
he's he's a he's like just a walking
like a goat yeah yeah but he's not like
as relevant right now as he was right
isn't that nuts he just did the super
bowl i mean no i know that but they i
mean that was like a thing like oh we're
getting everyone back together it wasn't
like uh like he sounds pretty heavy
still little kids like my little sister
will look at him like you looked at your
parents favorite music right oh that's
wild right yeah [ __ ] yeah that is so
crazy also like people that grew up on
him like when they're old people are
going to be singing his music as like 75
years old i can't wait for the face
tattoo generation to get old it's like
we've never experienced anything like
this i love it you know what i mean
i was like working on a script about
that actually
yeah we're not working on a show with
the
with our development team about this is
the at least for us this is like the
first time that we're gonna see
people getting really old with
gangsta rap and tattooed faces and
things like that and that's going to be
a [ __ ] trip yeah it is going to be a
trip imagine my grandma 90 now sings
like the ink spots you know what i mean
she sings the music from the floor
here's the thing
when we're 90 we're going to be like you
know [ __ ]
with a fat dick for that mouth you know
what i mean that's crazy but everybody
also just gets their tattoos removed now
they're just like whatever i'll get them
removed yeah but let me i know guys had
a neck tattoo jamie kelstein used to
have neck tattoos there did you would
never even know he had them now they're
just gone
like so people i think are just like
whatever by the way guys the fans are
exploding we're running out of time okay
oh yeah
yeah all right are they going nuts
yeah they're going nuts what are we
saying we're doing
ham and cheese there's corned beef on
rye
man
all right
where are we in the app
oh we started reminiscing
yeah
20 minutes left before we get to start
the next episode let's go ready yeah one
two three no matter what happens i love
you no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you time to
b-a-t-t-l-e
okay all right
now you have said time and time again to
be ham and cheese is your favorite
sandwich cheese is
outside of peanut butter and jelly
especially if we're talking processed
sliced meats
i think even maybe as much i mean i i
hold two sandwiches on a pedestal that i
think they are the king of sandwiches
they are the yankees they are the they
are everything they are peanut butter
and jelly and ham and cheese ham and
cheese is the quintessential
childhood sandwich even more so than
anything else people might throw bologna
at me but i don't think so i think it's
ham and cheese as a child i was a
finicky eater and i discussed this on
the pb and j battle versus grilled
cheese which i i believe i lost and i
cannot believe it i didn't think there
was a sandwich that would be peanut
butter and jelly but or grilled cheese
would
what you did touche
i was a finicky eater i only ate two
sandwiches as a child peanut butter and
jelly ham and cheese and bologna but
like ham and cheese was my all-star and
to this day my two favorite sandwiches
remain the same all right well i mean
i love a ham and cheese
there's nothing
it's like what they did with peanut
butter and jelly and ham and cheese was
we discovered two tastes
that elevate each other to the point
where
alone they're not the same and together
they're better than the sum of their
parts though they're they're better they
are
some of their parts is better than alone
i don't know what i'm trying to say
yeah i got you i got you um
and i like it i like it because it's
mayo i like it with mustard i like it on
white bread i like it all right what
kind of chocolate chips
i like it toasted i like it every which
way cheese
bud i might get slack for this i want to
argue with paul version giannis pappas
over this we're talking about best
cheeses over a nice long text group
group text if you say swift swiss i'm
going to throw it away swear do you know
my second favorite cheese of all time is
is uh fresh mozzarella
but well what it's okay it's hot it's
tied but my first cheese
is what they call the fake cheese and i
understand what they're saying i don't
know why i like it maybe it just goes
back to my childhood but dude
i i'm gonna get cheer for this i love
yellow american cheese
i love american but i love white it's
not even real cheese which is well it's
not a brand yeah there's not like
but i love white american like if i eat
a ham and cheese it's white american or
nothing okay easy with the white
american okay but if i eat a corn beef
on rye which i'm arguing for it's a
swiss
i understand swiss i like swiss but not
with ham
some people love ham and swiss i think
it's an idiotic combination i can see it
but if i have a chance to get american
or anything a lot of people put cheddar
on that burger no way american american
on the burger american on the
burger grilled cheese yellow american on
the burger yeah white american on the
ham and cheese now white american on the
grilled cheese that's how i what do you
hate on a on yellow american which many
people do when it is in the biggest
foods of all time the ham and cheese the
cheeseburger
the grilled cheese i can tell you these
are power houses i can tell you why
people hate on it because people don't
know that american cheese a lot of
people don't know that american cheese
is a cheese you can actually get sliced
at your deli when you say today you know
that well i because i've had this
argument
when i say to people i love american
cheese on a sandwich they go that's
disgusting they're they're disgusted and
they go i don't understand why you're so
disgusted they go that [ __ ] in the
fridge aisle that and i go no not
velveeta individually wrapped slices
let's get some go to your deli and get
it sliced let's get something they don't
know people we're not talking craft
singles that's what they think you mean
oh we're not talking that i'm talking
i'll tell you what boom slice it up i
tell you what a craft single on a
cheeseburger is actually pretty goddamn
good because it melts in the really
weird good consistency i understand so
right after i said we're not talking
craft we were talking crap so let me
tell you though about the corned beef on
rye and why i picked this
the last time a sandwich changed my life
which happened
the last time which means i would love
to hear every time well
i think as you're growing up
you try new series tell me about the
first time tell me about the first and
last time i also changed your life and i
after that i'll tell you about when the
the night the dj saved my life oh
i love it you guys know that that's a
jam kids
do you remember when we were do you
remember we were super young friends but
i i always realized that i turned on and
go did you guys know that
do you do you guys know that one yes i
had dj say my life do you remember
do you remember uh when we were on
vacation together we were in the pool
and we were super drunk and stoned i'll
never forget it and and on the speaker
last night dj played my life was playing
played that [ __ ] and i i you we were
really tuned up and i i reeled you in
with a long story
about getting into an altercation and
then the dj this and that and then i i
told it for like three minutes and at
the end i go that night a dj
and you were like you son of a [ __ ]
what happened
anyway
listen
when you're a kid sandwiches reshape
everything because you don't you don't
because you don't know what the
possibility is your flavor your taste
profiles are constantly changing you're
being introduced to more and more tastes
and things like that so you're
discovering foods a lot for the first
time exactly some of them some of them
really blow your bowls yeah exactly so
you get a for instance you'll get a
bologna and cheese with mustard and then
somebody else is your mustard too late
in life somebody introduced you to
blondie and cheese with some mayonnaise
and some tomato and you go whoa oh my
god that's so good or somebody will give
you a ham and cheese and then they'll
say have you ever tried the you know
dijon whatever
it keeps changing you start learning all
the possibilities you have lunch meat
roast beef for the first time and you go
i thought all you could have this meat
was with steak was the only form of this
roast beef sandwich would go nice
against something yeah
uh hot roast beef
i probably could i don't think i'm gonna
get like a regular roast beef listen but
listen but hold on you ate corned beef
as a child the first time i ever when i
was
beef i was like 19 or 22 or something
okay when i was 11 years old or so i
can't believe that i see a picture of an
eleven-year-old derosa chomping on a
cornfield yeah smoking a cigarette with
a cool man sandwich yeah yeah
in a police in a police station
ry you were dabbling with ryan as a
child this is what i'm trying to tell
you
i didn't know what rye bread was
there was a food court at the king of
pressure mall right near where i grew up
that was our mall they had an amazing
food court they had a deli in there it's
a chain deli at the time was called
bane's deli i don't think they exist
anymore
bane's deli had was called the corned
beef special which is a common sandwich
you find at jewish delis and stuff like
that my mom brought me there
for the to the mall for the day and then
she we went to the food court and she
goes i think you should try this
sandwich i think you'll like it that is
an adult profile right an adult flavor
profile she's corned beef she ordered it
for me and the she goes i go what's on
it she goes well
you like beef it's corned beef it's
different i go okay you like coleslaw i
go uh-huh she goes you like russian
dressing i go yeah she goes that's
what's on it she gives it to me
i eat this thing
i was sprung i was like this is so it
was wrong dude i couldn't get enough of
it i couldn't get enough of it it was
like almost like mcdonald's with me
where i would say to my mom like can we
please go to the mall and go to baines
deli
and get a corned beef special and that
was it that was the last time i had a
sandwich that changed where i was like
this is what you can do with a sandwich
i think i think it's a tight corned beef
uh on rye was like maybe like at st
patties at like an irish pub like when i
was like in my late teens or early 20s
and i was like it's okay well
it's it's a very distinct taste
um i think it's i think it's a learned
i think i think i think you have to
acquire the taste for it
and i think that if you have it
once
you could time out from it for quite
some time a ham and cheese is an
everyday sandwich a ham and cheese at
the least is you could have a ham and
cheese weekly
you can have a corned beef on rye weekly
oh easily weekly really i could have a
couple of just like that it's so rich
and heavy and great the only reason the
only thing that ever stops me from
having a corned beef on rye
is if i have stuff to do that day
obviously it's not a sandwich yeah right
so you eat it but i gotta be honest with
you too
i gotta be honest with you too a ham and
cheese in the middle of the day isn't
making me feel great either you know why
look processed lunch meat ham is one of
the worst things you can put in your
body i think sodium is off the charts
it's so high that i get the low sodium
and i still feel like i'm i'm going to
go into a salt coma
right and also too the brand depends
you got to get the right band and
there's a lot of
foreign watts but i do enjoy it boar's
head is the outboard which is online
right now when i speak ham and cheese
i'm speaking boar's head ham i like it
shredded thin
and when you go on the road when you go
outside
it's all we sell here in new york when
you go on the road especially like in
the midwest and stuff i can't believe it
i thought it was like the number one
they don't sell it and you get into this
weird video
or black forest hand they slice it thick
you get in some dangerous cold cuts out
there in the middle of america yeah i'm
telling you the two leading branches out
there
are deets and watson and boers head i
prefer deets and watson because i grew
up with deets and watson it sounds like
a law firm i know
and i'll tell you something
one
[ __ ]
it sounds like a like just gonna try to
make a lawyer joke it sounds like a
touring like banjo act yeah we need
normand in here for
uh
he'll be up he'll be here soon yeah
he'll be here for the next one i don't
know when these are coming out but
norman's going to be guessing
the deli is kind of like a law firm
you go in there are you sued for the
move
you got a briefcase kind of looks like
the same way
i got problems i got problems
i got a lawsuit against me i need i need
a lawyer i need i need to i need a
helper and he's like what do you say
when you're going to a law firm and made
a pickle
[Music]
oh yeah i got all sorts of problems
there and then the deal goes well we
sell him
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
the physicality we're doing it all
norman grab yourself a little plastic
green cup from behind the bar we're
going to have a few drinks while you're
on with us buddy
um so
so here's my thing i understand that the
ham and cheese is more of a common
sandwich but
you gotta you gotta be careful about
what ham you're getting because somebody
makes you a ham and cheese and they put
a honey ham on there
gross
they put a black farm
no but i'm saying some people think
that's the hand let's go basics ham
cheese white america what kind of hair
what kind of no no mayo what are you
talking about i'm talking to my man no
i'm talking about just a dude i go
straight up
you can't have a drink white american uh
white bread yeah you can have it dry
sure you can nah yes you can better help
better help i like better help this
podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy
relationships take work folks and a lot
of us will drop anything to go help
someone we care about we'll go out of
our way to help other people to treat
other people well but how often do we
give that treatment to ourselves i've
only learned recently uh for sure that
self-care and cell treatment is very
important and therapy is important
that's one of the ways i take care of
myself i agree i agree i think uh you
know a lot of people do it by hitting
the gym uh they make time for their
haircut uh they try therapy uh and but
at the end of the day no matter what
you're doing you are your greatest
aspect so invest the time in yourself
the effort into yourself like you do for
other people okay like that's important
it's mental gym people go to the gym all
the time they exercise you got to do the
same thing for your brain it's the
reason i go to therapy on a regular
basis you just get stuff out you process
stuff and it's just good health it's
just good mental health i talked about
therapy on this episode i talked we
talked about it on this episode yeah we
believe in it do it for yourself the
podcast is sponsored by betterhelp and
tastebud listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com taste buds
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com
taste buds give a try and see why over 2
million people have used better help
online therapy
folks whether saving money and spending
less uh getting organized or losing
weight or you know just thinking of
whatever worthwhile goals that you're
trying to set for yourself for this
brand new year of 2022
at the top of many people's lists
is learning a new language that's where
babel comes in we love babble a language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions
these fit these lessons take about 15
minutes it's a perfect way to learn a
new language on the go other language
learning apps use a.i for lesson plans
that's very impersonal but babel lessons
were created by over a hundred language
experts uh the teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
yeah i mean it's how you used to learn
in school yeah they do this like it's
it's fun learning yeah uh 14 different
languages which we always talk about
including all the hits german italian
french spanish etc uh they have a speech
recognition technology that also helps
you with your pronunciation so not just
learning the context but the
pronunciation i think that's one of the
best features honestly well also in
addition to the lessons through babel
you can access podcasts games videos
stories and even live classes so there's
a host of things it comes with a 20 uh
20 day money back guarantee
start your new language learning journey
today with babel right now when you
purchase a three month babble
subscription you're gonna get an
additional three months free that's six
months for the price of three just go to
babble.com and use our promo code
tastebuds that's b a b b e l dot com
code taste buds babble language for life
corned beef babe is a niche sandwich at
best people have it uh if you're not
irish and you don't have high blood
pressure and rosacea you're not having
corned beef all the time you're having
corned beef on the holidays if you're
going to a a deli that like a jewish
jelly or something that really slice it
up and make a nice but on the holidays
what the hell are you doing patties i
mean like you know what i mean you have
it like then no you have it any day you
have if you're going to a pub or a gas
store about something like that oh not a
pup i'm talking i go you you have corned
beef
at home i go to oh i'll do it at home
you have corned beef brother hot i will
buy a corned beef make it myself in my
oven and then slice it and make corn
beef sandwiches
but also too i'll go to a jewish deli
i'll go to second avenue deli i'll go to
um
is another one
but but like like i don't like the
corned beef stock the style of corned
beef the least is the what about the
fatty and all that it's just it's you
know brother it's so corn beef doesn't
repeat on you for days
no it doesn't you eat a corned beef
later that day you're not just
just
burping up corn beef not at all i'm not
just saying that i'm not just saying
really and what else is on there with
the rye
my favorite of course it's cold flawless
it's coleslaw russian dressing and then
maybe some swiss cheese but sometimes
the swiss cheese puts it a little too
over the top for me where i'm like oh
man this is a heavy sandwich i'd go
french dip before i go corn before
that's crazy you're nuts you're nuts
frank you want to talk about a boring
sandwich i mean i like a french dish i
respect your moxie because i think
you're going to get [ __ ] canned here
because i think ham and cheese is good
because you have a you have a knack for
picking
the most mainstream american
man because we sat down i said
i said we were going to do we were going
to do ham and cheese versus hot dog yes
we were going to do that we thought they
were both derivative of pork
and we thought they were like kids kids
on the kids menu and we thought they
were different enough but both
powerhouses to go up against each other
i tell you right now i think you made a
mistake because you came in and said you
know what i'll do actually a sandwich
i'll do corned beef i love it you said i
can't
wait to do corn i can't go out loud i'm
excited about it now you're gonna tell
me i have a knack for picking very
popular sandwiches
i didn't say i didn't think i would win
with corned beef i said i'm ready to do
corned beef because i feel that
passionate passionately about it corned
beef on rye with coleslaw and russian
dressing is my favorite sandwich of all
time so much so i won't serve it in my
own sandwich shop because we don't have
rye bread we do everything on our home
bake rolls and i won't do i won't do
misjustice to it i won't or injustice to
it i won't do it it's a sacred sandwich
to me what why didn't somebody invent a
rye roll
that just blow your mind did i just blow
everybody's mind i think it's probably
really hard why hero bread i think it's
probably really hard to do i don't know
anything about because a bunch of the
fans wrote in they're anti-rye because
it's not on the menu here
oh real come on
i can't win with these your own people
are eating you alive
i can't win with these people i got to
be honest corned beef i did you do you
eat corned beef the way you could eat
ham and cheese frequently you eat you're
going straight to the grave buddy you're
going straight to the grave that's a
widow maker you talk like ham and cheese
is some kind of health food
that's in a vending machine at a gym
it's it's a terrible food i don't even
know where corned beef comes from i
don't know where the beef comes from
where does corn beef come from the cow
but why is it corn
i've never it's the seasoning but i
don't know why it's called corned beef
so this is the shavings of a cow
brother i got news for you corned beef
is is better for you than ham is corn i
don't know i don't know pimp give a
statistic give us calories on corned
beef versus ham i guarantee you ham is
worse for you first of all it says
corned beef is made with beef brisket
it's brisket all right that is much
better for you than him pimp give us a
calorie count on ham versus corn meat
ham is cured dude there's nothing worse
for you than a cured meat
and corned beef is more straight up just
slice it up it's brisket you know what
though i look at corned beef sometimes
and it just looks like they're both
around the same calorie
don't get me around which one is it 213
for corned beef and 203 for him get the
[ __ ] out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here give me a
sodium count on both sides
i want a sodium count on both now one
thing you've overlooked is that uh ham
and cheese goes to school lunch so it's
nostalgic
no i i know i'm saying a ham with cheese
since i'm a kid ham and cheese it's for
a limited pound i know i see this dumb
child that doesn't understand what food
is i don't know i think that even the
most refined palette i think chef gordon
ramsay would love a nice ham and cheese
i think we all would but i think are you
guys ready for the sodium yeah uh 827
milligrams in the corned beef
and sixteen hundred eighty-four in the
hand
no oh [ __ ]
oh my god
oh my god i didn't think that give me
fat give me spam
saturated fat and fat give me it give me
it
you're you're way fatter saturated fat
is probably out the [ __ ] [ __ ] that
is insane
uh ham is eight grams
corned beef
is one minute
corn beef 16 grams double the fat
sodium is going to kill you before that
fat will saturate by the way i got news
for you
it's good fat because it's animal fat
that's not bad fat i don't know if
that's how it goes buddy no bad fat just
like that is like oil
whatever olive oil
i don't think good fat is vanity is see
if corned beef is good good good fats
says
ham is uh 2.5 saturated fat and the
corned beef is five grams
double the saturated and regular fat the
good fats are unsaturated right oh
all right
all right
the history of by the way corned beef is
like a new york city staple yes it's
like irish you know yes that i know but
but if you leave here it's jewish more
jewish right
um it was irish no no i know it's like
traditionally an irish dish but i feel
like in new york it's very much a joke
you are the only child in the history of
this world that was a that that corned
beef changed your life that you were a
young child ordering corned beef on the
rank i think of corn beef even now and
at my age even now and i feel like
people with walkers order corned beef
there's a reason today it's a holiday or
people everywhere
i would like to get a statistical
breakdown of of of what color hair what
is this people do i bet
who orders corned beef i bet you 80 of
them have
pure white hair all right
all right and guess what everybody who
wears hair and cheese has no pubic hair
because they're children they're little
dumb children well guess what we are the
future
into a restaurant order a ham and cheese
i don't know who what restaurants there
is that's what i'm saying is because
it's child's food
come on
come on look it's a great sandwich but
it's basic [ __ ] [ __ ] that's all i'm
saying it's basic [ __ ] [ __ ] for a
reason popular music is called pop
because it's the most popular it's the
reason it's the most popular it's the
most appealing there's a reason it's the
most appealing it's the most amenable i
will say this in closing arguments i
will say this in closing arguments you
put a tray down and on that tray is a
corned beef with coleslaw and russian
dressing a side of potato salad and a
dill pickle heads
you're not
you're not there's
that is a lunch that is a dinner corned
beef makes its way into breakfast with
corned beef hash all right this is a
meal sandwich a ham and cheese is at
best a passive lunch or a snack that's
it you think it's at best a passive
lunch or a snack yes well i got to tell
you don't underestimate snacks don't all
right yeah fine fine all right you guys
want to hear some tweets you want to go
no you can read us a couple real quick
okay here's one uh corned beef reminds
me of how my grandmother looks and
smells my grandmother's that girl
she also
she also writes my grandmother's
deceased
corned beef
out of the gate it might be the winner
corn beef also reminds me a little bit
of like mold flesh or a very bad uh
female
i said
oh my god and ham doesn't that means
bright pink ham no it just reminds me of
like a like a really nice sweaty that's
the other one it's so sweaty
a beautiful
wet meat it's kind of gross
it's a wet meat
good
somebody wrote if if joe side sided with
corned beef i'm never going to joey
roses
god
all right let's hear
um corned beef on rye is not a lunchable
flavor
well that's a great point do you know
lunchable i mean you're not even eating
food
you know what i'm saying anything that
could be mimicked in the way that
lunchables mimic food is but you know
come on what are we talking about you're
seeing that as a plus or minus something
minus i'm saying i'm saying you corned
beef is a quality meat like
ham is a pro for the most part is a very
mimicable process kind of experience
normand
choose
norman you can come on here
choose one
classic ham and cheese sandwich or
corned beef what are you choosing
[Music]
you're not gonna like it but i'm going
corned beef thank you thank you
i couldn't have i guess that one i never
would have guessed you didn't have ham
and cheese that's like special needs
kids
come on
the new victoria's secret marker that
corned beef is like a incontinence wait
wait wait wait wait let mark read it let
mark read some of the tweets that'll be
funny
hey how are you pimpy
all right ham and cheese i can make it
home any day corned beef is more of a
treat there you go okay
all right all right nobody with taste
buds is picking a grilled cheese over a
corned beef on rye grilled cheese
all right
corned beef with mustard is like a
ferrari ham and cheese is a ford topaz
no contest
one more pimp
all right i loved ham and cheese as a
kid
and it's just as good today especially
if you toast it oh
pimp let's give the winner to the first
tweet mark you can read the first tweet
corned beef reminds me of how my
grandmother looks and smells my
grandmother is deceased all right who's
the handle so we can tell them to follow
it's claire mooton
or mutton
m-u-t-t-o-n m-o-u-t-o-n mountain mouton
all right follow claire and pimp
who is our winner humble pie let's get
that drum roll in here pimpy oh and
which one are you voting pimp
how many votes
oh boy
ham and cheese and corned beef 9
390 votes okay
wow oh
ham and cheese wins in a landslide with
70 percent 70. holy oh my god baby
oh my god put a nail in the coffin that
is corned beef
bury it with all the old but to a bad
start this year yeah
you're up now like you're up now like
five to two listen to me you could have
played hot dogs for his hair and cheese
that you changed you changed the legend
it was hammer cheese there's hot dogs
we're doing never know we're doing hot
dogs
because we're doing hot dogs versus
chicken fingers soon okay and we decided
it was a better battle okay all right
that's coming up our next episode stay
tuned mark norman will be with us next
week to battle we're not going to tell
you just yet but thanks folks thanks for
tuning in uh
uh may 14th the beacon theater tickets
are on sale right now march 11th uh is
the ryman tickets on set right now march
12th to chattanooga god bless
savilecountercomedy.com
uh this comes out what next week i will
be in philadelphia at the punch line
march for in march for five shows and
then down to south by southwest i'm
doing a sandwich panel down there and
some stand up please come see them uh
and then in april i'm out west at the
irvine improv and then down to san diego
to do some shows get all your tickets at
joederosainfo.com i'll just say one
thing speaking of san diego and la you
need to up your game i'm there may 21st
and 22nd and i want to see a little more
activity in sales please thank you so
much thank you and also come to joey
roses we're here right now we're open
tuesday through
sunday go to
joeyrosesnyc.com for all your info i
still love you babe i love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man